what up space fam goes in here from
anime out Pro and today we're going to
be talking about how strong demon king
ton judo is if you enjoy seeing demon
Surtur videos on this channel and want
to keep them coming then show some love
for demon slayer by smashing that like
button and sharing this video if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future demon center videos to get
early access to our content including
Demon Slayer follow anime uproar audio
on Spotify or Apple music or wherever
else you listen to podcast a very
special thank you go sir enemy up for
patrons who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible [ __ ] you amazing
people at the end of the video
keep in mind in these videos I go over
all the relevant manga information to
get a sense of exactly how strong a
character is so obviously a video about
demon king ton zero will have plenty of
spoilers you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into it as we all
hopefully know by now the last chapter
Demon Slayer was crazy AF and in it
tangelo became the next demon king moves
on realized that his flesh will
disappear because of the sunlight he
would die so since he couldn't become
the perfect life form by which he means
a regenerating demon who was immune to
the Sun he decided to pass on his dream
to another specifically to our very own
shown and protagonist the reasons he
chose tan judo are important so let's go
over them
according to moose on tundra will
conquer the sunlight and become the
strongest demon the king of demons here
interestingly enough rules on is nodding
at the fact that there are other demons
out there still so continuation maybe
let's hope so but for the purposes of
this video it's enough to notice that
moves on is suggesting here that tundra
will surpass his own power not just as
post Tama you're poisoning power but his
max peak power there are two key reasons
why Muslim believes that Tundra will
surpass him one is the fact that since
he's deser Cole's brother and shares her
blood he will be able to like Diamond a
Zuko develop immunity to the Sun to he
is the only person alive able to use the
same breathing style as you Ichi who
moves on calls that monster the breath
of the Sun is the original and
longest breath style and yuuichi used it
too embarrassed and traumatized moves on
the demon king of pop himself when he
was at his strongest as we saw with Kai
Goku and upper moon one Kakashi bow
demons can use breath styles and in fact
they seem to be enhanced by demon blood
because of these two factors immunity to
the Sun and knowledge that the breath of
the Sun style rules on pores
all of his blood and power into ton zero
this is a big deal - we know that in
general the more blood moves on get
someone the stronger they'll become he
gave more blood to lower moon one and
move to make him stronger the danger
though is that Muslims blood is so
powerful and poisonous that most people
cannot withstand a large amount and die
only those that can handle the amount of
blood given survive and become stronger
the more blood he gives the less the
chance of survival with tundra of Musa
takes a risk he gives her protagonist
all of his blood in other words
significantly more than he's given
anyone else including the extremely
powerful akasa dolma and Kakashi bow and
Mulan was right Tundra does survive
before even taking in the blood Tundra
was the strongest even Sarah alive and
yes even stronger than the pillars he
possessed the strongest breath style the
breath of the Sun he acts as the
see-through world before the others and
he could enter the insanely powerful
selfless state that he used to get the
better of akiza when he cut off Paco's
head he was far ahead of ghee you a
pillar himself already but then he
passed out gained access to memories of
UDT using the breath of the Sun style
properly and then he improved even more
he got even stronger he went on to fight
one on one against Mouzon after moves on
just took out multiple pillars at the
same time including the strongest pillar
Gill may and sana me was moose on
getting weaker because of Tommy knows
poisoning yes but I still think that
it's significant that Tanja could do so
well right after Mulan took out the
others tons you to weaken from
exhaustion and the infection on his face
was able to connect the Sun breath style
successfully like your Ichi Musa points
out the tundra still wasn't on your
each's level but he was still amazing
considering the circumstances he lasted
against moved on one on one for over to
chat
chapters until Igor jumped in to help if
Tantra was in good shape when the battle
started he might have not even needed
iguras help but as things stood the
poisoned and injured human ton judo had
trouble getting oxygen to the point
where he couldn't even see now done judo
won't have that problem anymore there
are so many advantages that demons have
over humans that it's not even fair in
the fight between a tango quit Akasa
Akasa told the flame pillar that his
serious wounds which included a crushed
eye broken ribs and internal bleeding
would be healed in the blink of an eye
if he were a demon now the Tundra's a
demon all of his wounds as we saw with
his infected eye and regrown arm are
gone he's back to tip-top shape and
arguably even better since he's been
enhanced by demon blood he knows he
couldn't bring himself to cut tendrils
neck but even if he did I sincerely
doubt that that would work moves on
Alcazar anchor coachable all had the
ability to grow their heads back acha
san ko-ko Tchibo were primarily defeated
because they gave up the will to fight
not because their heads were cut off
since control got even more moves on
blood than each of the upper moons
mentioned he should be able to easily
grow back a cut off head and unlike the
others he's immune to the Sun thus I
believe that beating tundra physically
will be impossible he's invincible the
only way to beat him is going to be to
make him give up the will to fight even
the red blades that did so much damage
against Mulan should not be effective
against tan judo the red blades
represent the Sun but if tundra is
immune to the Sun then red blades
shouldn't be any more effective than a
normal blade thus if as Mulan assumes
tundra will be able to use a demon
enhanced version of the breadth of the
Sun style and his demon form and he's
arguably the strongest character we've
ever seen
yuuichi is more skilled in swordsmanship
no doubt but if tundra is immune to the
Sun and red blades and will regenerate
from any wound then not even you Ichi
could do anything to him eventually
demon king ton zero would get a hit on
your Ichi and as we know from Moo's on
one hit can be enough to poison a human
for the first time ever
there is a possibility that there's a
character who is not necessarily as
skilled or talented as your Ichi but
could potentially beat him in a fight to
the death
keep in mind I didn't even mention that
demon king ton judo will probably have
an Opie blood demon art too on top of
all of this so to me it wouldn't make
any sense of tundle loss in a physical
battle to any of the living characters
even if they were all working together
my assumption is that they're going to
have to somehow get through to him
emotionally as they fight just like they
did with Icaza and Coco tchibo
strength-wise demon king tangelo should
be invincible the strongest character
we've ever seen in Demon Slayer at least
so far and that is it for today's video
let me know your thoughts in the
comments if you enjoyed this video and
want to see more like it smash that like
button and share this video with a
friend if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future Demon Slayer videos to get
early access to our content including
Demon Slayer follow anime up or audio on
Spotify or Apple music or wherever else
you listen to podcasts lastly the
YouTube ad rates have significantly
dropped recently so the help and support
we're getting from our anime outpour
patrons is now more important than ever
a very special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank the legend
acknowledged by Lorde we go senpai sama
himself baby ray and the one tier
patrons the ones who stay atop all clans
Stephan and Radha a Lola and autumn the
world stealers the school bus Theisen
Kirino a quiet respect and potato fuh
and our pro hero to your patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King zelgius Anatole
Kazansky angel Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP Ted no Ted Salter Joel
Stanton very Gucci Alisha actor animal
69 jessica calif on he no
me and water emperor otaku JCCC waka and
the coach thank you all so so much if
you enjoy work you can always support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
slash anime uproar and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll gain name feature in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out P channel calm enemy
out for link in the description if
you're interested you can also now join
the YouTube channel and support more
content that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us you can get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you